ich frage mich auch manchmal von der was
für eine Erwartungshaltung hier
gegenüber der FDP formuliert wird das
ist ja absolut nicht realistisch noch
mal wir haben nicht die absolute
Mehrheit in Deutschland
wir haben eine ganz andere Pandemie
Politik in diesem Land etabliert als
bisher existiert hatte nur einfach mal
gesagt
Erwartungshaltung ist dass die FDP in
der Regierung genau das macht was sie im
Wahlkampf versprochen hat das haben wir
auch gemacht das überrascht mich dass
sie das jetzt sagen ja
wartungshaltung des Publikums gegenüber
allen Parteien und das wäre aber dann
nie mehr herauskommen aus den
Schutzmaßnahmen weil es immer wieder
neue Fälle geben wird so wie es auch
trotz Grippeschutzimpfung immer wieder
Grippe erkrankt hat
immer wieder wir sind im Übergang von
der Pandemie zu einer endemischen
Entwicklung und wenn wir das zum Maßstab
machen solange wir noch Corona Fälle
haben ein nennenswerte zahlen müssen wir
immer Schutzmaßnahmen ergreifen das ist
meine Befürchtung dass wir dann aus dem
Kreislauf nicht mehr heraus